yeah you don't eat none of them or
anything you're just no you're just
waiting for the cops to come no so well
they come and they're the SWAT team
comes in
it's banging on the door like come out
I'm telling them [ __ ] you I'm not coming
out cuz I'm no I'm just like oh man what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do and then I'm like
well I'm gonna be dope sick as [ __ ] so I
hit pills to where I could bring him in
ya don't really want to talk about how I
brought him here just so no detail I
don't know what else I don't want to
[ __ ] up anybody else's chance to bring
[ __ ] into jail everybody in jail jail
sucks in drugs make you feel a little
better but anyways oh you found a way to
snuck sneak him in I snuck him in how
many of them I probably had like there
had been like 20 of them okay so that
probably lasted me like two days so this
is before they broke down the door
whatever no they didn't actually break
down the door okay I know we're jumping
ahead a little bit but yeah so they're
banging on the door told me to come out
I'm telling I'm not coming out and then
after I figure out how to bring them in
and I didn't bring him in my [ __ ]
safety deposit box in the jail purse
yeah in the prison pocket didn't do that
that's what everybody's probably
thinking right yeah I'm sure people
don't what if I had to got a lot of
space up there yeah so finally after I
get situated how I want to do it I got
what I need I'm like [ __ ] it I'm like
I'm coming out so I tell I I bang on the
door back and I'm like I'm coming out
cuz I'm like I'm probably gonna get
[ __ ] shot so I remember opening this
this back door and it's right by the
back exit door to like the shop and
there's there's got to be like 10 or 15
red dots on this [ __ ] back door so
when I open the door swings this way and
the exit doors here so I just see all
these [ __ ] red dots on this back edge
oh my god yeah so I'm like so I just out
of the doorway I just got to stick my
hands out after you saw the red dots I
saw the red dots I go I go like this I'm
like I'm coming out and then so I just
try to go like I like alright what let
me see what I'm doing the movies or
something yeah so I just kind of like
I'm coming out cuz you don't know what
to [ __ ] do there's just so much going
on it's like kind of don't want to get
shot man I tried to kill myself but I
didn't want to do it so definitely I
want to like yeah alright here so I I
finally get out
and I had sweat pants on too so I
[ __ ] turned out I turned around put
my hands on my head and then they
[ __ ] bum rush me I mean my [ __ ]
pants were around my [ __ ] knees
my little coke dicks flopping around
[ __ ] everywhere before what the coke
dick it's like you ever seen when those
old school door stoppers yeah okay
smaller yeah so then I'm sitting in the
back of the cop car like in front of
this [ __ ] pharmacy law I remember
beta news and I come in there and you're
just sitting there in the [ __ ] back
of a cop car no tent just like fishbowl
and then all you're saying I'm like all
I'm thinking about like goddamn I'm like
am I gonna like ever get out again and
cuz I was 24 when that happened I was 18
yeah yeah 19 anybody so you're sitting
back in this cop car in front of the
[ __ ] pharmacy people all around news
there and you're like cool like feel
like just a total piece of [ __ ] to keep
you in the car I was probably out front
of the pharmacy for like two or three
hours cuz I got to do like all this [ __ ]
and then they [ __ ] probably take you
but I was sitting in the car kind of
like away from everybody but like
everybody's walking by you looking in
and now it's just kind of like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] how do you feel about what
just happened how do you feel at your
performance in there we're going we're
going to jail and then like that's all
that's kind of running through my mind
is like how long I'm gonna be gone for
kind of deal mm-hmm and then and then I
was like oh dude you know what's so
[ __ ] - so we get in a book I get
booked well we go in and you get like
strip-searched kind of depend depends on
how ID search no they don't ever they
don't cavity search yeah okay if they
feel like you've stuck something in
something they'll put you in a room to
where there's like no running water so
till you like [ __ ] or something like
that so they know yeah look put you in
confinement buy buy yourself something
yeah so like that like that but I mean
you get butt-ass naked
you didn't request the cavity search I
did they they told me to [ __ ] off
here's a bologna sandwich yeah but it's
I mean it's I mean but now like it's
it's kind of like I've been I've been
strip-searched so much like I don't
really don't give a [ __ ] I would have
kind of actually battle well we'll get
to that later too I would battle if you
were the guard and I was me we would
both try to make each other more
comfortable as possible
ha ha so like what would you do ah oh
here let me let me give a story so I
could we get bullying I get
strip-searched you get your clothes back
and then you're in booking you're in
central booking where they do your
fingerprints in your photos yeah yeah I
mean Pinellas County Jail is so [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ] thank
you and then uh so you're probably I was
probably down there for like 20 hours
and you're in this room the concrete
room no windows and just for like for
Lent lights like you do not know what
[ __ ] time it is but just on the clock
on the wall right but if it says 8:00
you're like loners let's eat in the
morning right at night
yeah right so there's a couple things up
one bathroom and there's a guard
standing right outside of it that you
can go use but it's like there's no
stalls no nothing and then I was like
well I'm kind of getting dope sick so I
was like oh if I can
I [ __ ] crushed up a [ __ ] Rock seat
in this bathroom and thank God nobody
walked in when I was doing it and
[ __ ] started it while I was in
bookings bathroom I just did I didn't
give a [ __ ] do you like right and they
got the door what are you gonna add five
more years on to my sentence yeah yeah
run it run it together I mean it's the
same [ __ ] yeah
sign up [ __ ] yeah so um yeah then you
finally go to jail I [ __ ] I knew a
bunch of people I went in the cell was
because I [ __ ] just left there
[ __ ] yeah four months four months ago
no I didn't mean so uh so then you got
to deal with that it's like it's like oh
[ __ ] walk of shame dude I was high
for two days feeling good because you
had that stash that you brought with you
I didn't even call anybody until I ran
out of girls because I mean it was super
embarrassing for me to like after
everything kind of wore off yeah with
the drugs and then and I knew that you
knew that it was probably all over the
news too right oh yeah so it would come
on I was
they got TVs in these bods memory I
swear dude I was on news for like three
[ __ ] days man yeah it was a it was a
slow news week in seminole yeah you
heard about it too
yeah I heard about yeah I was working I
was working a construction and I was
like riding in a van to Sarasota in the
back of a van with a bunch of other
Mexican dudes and it was like 6:00 in
the morning and it was on Bubba the Love
Sponge and they said Jake James I'm like
no [ __ ] way I know I text Luke he's
like yep mom called no because Bubba
would do that a lot about the news and
I've listened to Bubba since I would
loved it like [ __ ] like religiously
yeah and I don't know how to Ned yeah
only that is real yeah so that it's like
oh Bobo's talking [ __ ] will [ __ ] you you
fat piece of [ __ ] yeah look at you now
Bubba I'm on the radio anyway double
fisted Blue Jay on the backside
McGillicuddy yeah just deal with that
being dope sick like yeah I would trade
my whole [ __ ] trays for like juice
for what my whole like you get fed like
three times a day okay
shitty [ __ ] meals yeah I could not
eat anything I would for like a week I
would just trade I would just drink
juice I would just trade my trays for
like people just use you probably even
have an appetite huh no you're like
you're just like just [ __ ] your
brains out not hungry diarrhea hold high
just I just [ __ ] dude it's just like
you're a little it's like you're a
little [ __ ] baby yeah just curled up
in a corner how long did that last part
it took like it took like a month and I
did that twice and like that's how
[ __ ] up it was like the first time I
went like I went through that yeah and
then to get out and like do the same
shits like that just shows you like I'm
either really [ __ ] up or that shit's
really [ __ ] up so I just went through
like a true detox was like when you're
in prison because I remember yeah mom
and dad put you through some like
like medically-induced yeah I don't know
I don't know what that was either yeah
because you're in a coma for a couple of
days and the new detox and you wake up
that was weird but you know that
suffering but Wow
you have to feel that suffering dude oh
yeah yeah yeah because like oh that's
what I tried that's when I was selling
them for yeah like two months and then I
started doing them again yeah I think
that's a really important thing I think
to hit on is like if you don't feel that
suffering like when you're trapped in
that that darkness that you've created
around yourself then you don't really
know the pain that you have to go
through to feel it so you go through it
like they just sleepwalking pretty much
and then you have no reason not to do it
again because like oh well whatever I
can just like numb myself to numbing
myself and it's just like this
continuation of blocking out things that
you have to go through to progress as a
person
yeah no you need pain to grow I mean if
you don't feel pain you gotta suffer the
consequence just like the whole [ __ ]
touching the stove thing dude yes yeah
you got to feel pain to grow and get
past [ __ ] but this how [ __ ] up this
place was like before when you have like
your meeting with these people it's just
all a [ __ ] scam so they're like
they're like oh do you need pill like
they gave me a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] like
oxycontin 80s before because I was like
oh I'm sick they're like oh we write you
a script and then like in jail and pray
I don't know this was like at this detox
this was this was I don't forgot even
when that was they prescribed you
adderall - well yeah so you go through
this detox saying so it's like it's like
a day or whatever so you wake up and
you're not you're not dope sick I don't
I don't even know what the [ __ ] it is
like you some opiate blockers or
whatever at that thing and they I claim
like if you take opiates again you'll
die oh no that's one suboxone started
coming in because they put me on
suboxone book centers wait what's that
it's a it's an opiate blocker but people
take them to die on them yeah it's
supposed to be to help you get off but
if you take like it opieop pills they
don't work yeah so like you're taking
suboxone if you take like if you do
heroin or [ __ ] oxys you're not gonna
get high from it okay
kind of deal so it kind of but it makes
you from not being dope sick to
hmm you're still [ __ ] kneeling good
yeah it's a weird thing yeah so I go
through this detox and when I get out
they prescribe me he prescribes me
adderall valium he's worth - no no no
you didn't give me an opiate it was like
four or five different other pills but
with me I'm like I [ __ ] love pills
right oh this is this is amazing yeah so
then I mean boy it did nowhere I think
that lasted like a couple weeks or
something like that that's pretty much
oh no because they told me they told me
don't do coke because you'll probably
die I think I did coke like four days
after that and a lot of a lot of [ __ ]
coke I was up in the [ __ ] mutt room
like I remember one time mom went on
like the family computer and like the
latest Google search was symptoms of
coke overdose like she had found oh do
you think Jake's doing drugs again well
Jake might have diabetes [ __ ] man I mean
that's like what I'm saying there's so
many [ __ ] things that happen that I
probably I don't remember I just know it
need a little kick start yeah they make
it very easy to be an addict in the
state of Florida they do and you know
like when you love somebody you'll do
anything you can - yeah there's no pain
yeah everybody's just like and you know
it's like it gets to the point where
it's like you're enabling this person
but you don't realize it because like
you don't want to help them you don't
know what this person wants and anything
that respond to positively they'll give
to them because they're actually
interacting with you in a way that isn't
just like [ __ ] you can I get money [ __ ]
you I don't need you in my life I hate
you everything I'm doing is because of
you
and you know it it pains you to see
somebody suffering like that and you
never truly understand the darkness that
they feel and you just want them to do
well and the best thing that you can do
is just let them go through it and just
be there when they need you
yeah